merci Monsieur le Commissaire
oui je vais voter en faveur de l'accord
entre l'Union européenne et la
Nouvelle-Zélande oui je soutiens les
avancées obtenues avec un partenaire
fiable ambitieux une démocratie
parlementaire qui nous ressemble oui je
soutiens les garanties environnementales
que contient l'accord avec la mention de
l'accord de Paris et avec enfin un
système de sanction oui je soutiens les
gains économiques concrets par les
entreprises européennes et français
ainsi que la reconnaissance des
indications géographiques alors nous
serons la seule forse politique
française capable d'assumer une telle
vision les autres délégations allant
souvent à l'encontre de leur groupe
européen restant dans un carcan
idéologique dépassé alors que cet accord
doit devenir un standard minimum un
standard pour toutes les négociations en
cours et à venir c'est seulement avec la
réciprocité des normes environnementales
et agricoles que nous avancerons et cet
accord les façonne c'est seulement ainsi
avec cet accord que nous façonnerons un
commerce régulé durable et juste alors
allons de l'avant avec cet accord ne
soyons pas des populistes comme peuvent
l'être l'extrême droite comme ils l'ont
fait tout à l'heure et véritablement
avançons pour façonner le commerce
mondial et ne restons pas dans les
dogmes du passé je vous
remercie